[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
one
two
three
four
fifth
fifth
fifth fifth fifth amendment
well it's not surprising
that the the biggest criminal to ever
enter our white house takes the fifth
amendment in his civil trial
in new york
today not surprising at all i wasn't
surprised were you surprised if you were
surprised oh
boy you are not paying attention you're
not paying attention you know it's
really funny because the last few days
we've had on and on and on the media is
really trying to make this out to be a
great thing for them to get ratings
around donald trump here
when they're saying oh what are the
ramifications for this it seems like it
seems like this is big government
and everyone is forgetting
that in new york
that he was gonna he did a deposition
today and he pled the fifth so he
doesn't self-incriminate himself
and the reason why
the reason why he would do this
is because his business the trump
organization his family business that
he's ran for decades
is charged with crimes
we keep forgetting this his cfo his
partner in his business and his business
itself is charged with crimes
he's a [ __ ] criminal why is it so
unprecedented
that a [ __ ] criminal a career
criminal who is whose business is
charged with crimes in the state of new
york and his cfo
allen weisselberg is also charged with
crimes in the state of new york
the the attorney general in new york
tisch james
deposed him and he pled the fifth so he
dealt didn't self-incriminate this
morning i mean it would be almost like
someone who ran for president and back
in 2016 would say only mobsters take the
fifth
of course we're gonna watch video of it
today
we got to see this idiot say these
things that and then he does them it's
all projection always every [ __ ] time
but why is the media so surprised and
it's so unprecedented and right-wingers
are so upset that the fbi would go raid
his home at mar-a-lago this is not
surprising it's not unprecedented it's
not it's unprecedented that you [ __ ]
morons still support this idiot
you [ __ ] morons put this bonehead in
office
and then act like he was the greatest
thing since sliced bread
after one impeachment after two
impeachments after he [ __ ] incited a
violent insurrection and tried to take
away our government and our democracy
this is not unprecedented this is
[ __ ] when someone tells that tell
them to [ __ ] off
it is not unprecedented that we in this
country treat a [ __ ] career criminal
like a career criminal
that is something we should continue to
do and we need more of it
so this morning him
him pleading the fifth
and taking the fifth amendment by the
way the statement that he wrote was not
written by him it was written by
attorneys
and that's the other thing that is if
there's something unprecedented here
it's that donald trump is keeping his
mouth shut
in new york
that's something that's unprecedented i
mean jesus christ he'd love to run his
[ __ ] mouth
especially to run his mouth in front of
a bunch of prosecutors
oh he would love nothing more than to
love that
but it is clear now in this case in new
york that donald trump is actually
listening to his legal counsel
at least to this degree in this moment
that the best thing for you to not go to
prison in new york is to keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut that's that is a that
is a sign
that he understands the ramifications
here at at a bare minimum
at a bare minimum
because we keep forgetting this the
business that he ran that he continued
to run and his criminal children
continued to run while he was president
united states while he was taking our
[ __ ] money
and breaking laws and criminal over the
place while his [ __ ] criminal
daughter his criminal sons and his
criminal son-in-law
were committing crimes financial crimes
and taking saudi money and chinese money
and everything else
that his business
is under criminal indictment
it's under criminal indictment as well
as his chief financial officer is under
criminal indictment
in the state of new york
this idea that the fbi going down to his
home and retrieving documents that the
government has tried to get and he has
refused to give them
under criminal under criminal penalty
that the fbi the department of justice
the federal law enforcement agency that
would that would charge him with such
crimes
that he has committed
that it's that it's so surprising that
the government would do such a thing
he's a former president yeah that's
that's the actual problem here
the problem is not that the fbi is
raiding him that that the state of new
york is after him for civil and criminal
charges
that the state of georgia is after him
for criminal charges for election fraud
and election tampering
that's not the prob the problem is that
he was a [ __ ] former president that's
the [ __ ] problem
and that these did he [ __ ] bonehead
still think it's a good idea because of
him grifting off of them
to make him the president again which i
am in hopes that he runs oh my god
nothing would please me more than for
him to
while he's in new york to come down the
gold escalator again
and announce that he's running again and
he's running as the next hitler or some
[ __ ] i would that would satisfy me
highly let's do that today
let's put donald trump on the ballot in
2022 let's do that because apparently
more of his candidates won
in the primary yesterday which is not a
bad thing everyone's like oh no
look
if anyone believes at this point that it
is going to be a good idea in the next
couple months going forward
that you're gonna get on your cheeto
dust knee pads and be a trump candidate
you are
you are out of your [ __ ] mind because
folks we
the people have to make punish them for
electing these candidates
we the people
we have the vote it's our government we
get to tell it what the [ __ ] to do
we
get to tell it what the [ __ ] to do
that's how it works the religious
through the religion the bible doesn't
get to tell it what to do
that donald trump and his [ __ ]
supporters don't get to tell it what to
do there's not enough of them
we the people get to tell this
government and your local government
your state government what the [ __ ] to
do
yesterday in missouri
a recreational marijuana referendum
appears on the ballot
huh seems kind of convenient i love it
looks like with that referendum on the
ballot that senate seat could be in play
folks
if people in missouri go vote for the
person who is for that amendment and go
vote for the amendment
it looks like it looks like we could
have a democratic senator which gives us
one more seat in the united states
senate these things are possible
stop believing that we just have all
lost already we are not
in a position of loss
the tide is turning
we also see today that
this inflation
the administration is doing things to
get inflation under control it's working
of course it is
i've been saying for months and months
and months stop believing the inflation
fear the fear-mongering about inflation
the fear-mongering about gas prices
gas prices are coming down crude is
coming down
inflation's coming down of course it is
keep your hats on it's going to be okay
the only thing we have to worry about
is that the fed
if the fed keeps raising interest rates
to draw us into a recession to force one
because that will force us into a
recession because what will happen is it
will cost more money to have money
and that's how it's how interest rates
work
buy a car buy a house buy anything
a lot of people buy things on credit a
lot of people a lot of struggling middle
class people live on credit
to make sure their house operates to
make sure their lives operate
and it's going to cost more money if
they keep raising the interest rates
so if we're gonna yell and scream about
the economy we need to be yelling and
screaming to the fed to lower the
interest rates that that that would help
but all their narratives all their
narratives every last one of them
are proving to be all [ __ ] hmm who
could have guessed that
who could have called that
of course they're nonsense of course
they're [ __ ] they're all [ __ ]
lies
for years and years and decades and
decades the republican party has always
been fascist
always have been a bunch of [ __ ]
fascists but they always thin veiled
their fascism
right they always thin veiled it with
conservatism or some sort of truth
some sort of tethering to some sort of
reality
my cab
taxes nah uh government spending you
know they always
they always really tagged it to some
sort even though it's still a [ __ ]
underlying lie it's not an outright
wholesale lie
the wholesale lies that they're trying
to sell
is going to backfire on them and you
have to make them pay the price with
your ballot you have to engage in your
democracy and i don't just mean going
and voting
register people to vote talk to people
about what is going on if you have some
spare change give to those campaigns
that can win
that are within striking distance
of taking up a governor's seat
your state legislator
a senate seat united states senate seat
a congress seat
help them
whether they're in your district or not
maybe maybe you want to send text
messages write letters send postcards
knock on doors whatever it is that
you're good at
whatever it is that you're good at you
should engage in your democracy in that
way and talk to your fellow your fellow
community members your family your
friends
the people you go to church with
have these discussions with them this is
very vital and very important to make
sure people understand what is at stake
here
if they go and mark any person's name on
a ballot
that is in support of trump and trumpism
american fascism
fascism in a manga hat
that's what's at stake here and we can
do this this is not this is not
difficult we did it in 2020 with a huge
pandemic going on
we piled eight million more votes on top
of donald trump because again i don't
think 81 million people voted for joe
biden
i think a lot of them a lot of that 81
million voted against trumpism
they didn't give a [ __ ] about joe biden
hell they may hate joe biden they just
they just were not going to put up with
a bunch of fascism in this country
and i think we can do that again in the
2022 midterms
and it's key
we have a lot of success us
pro-democracy people the people that got
out and and got to the polls and voted
in 2020
got us where we're at
we would not we would not have anything
that we have today
without georgia
having a big push in those runoffs
that is a huge deal we got to 50
and yeah it's not convenient when you
have kirsten cinema and joe manchin
showing for the other side
in most cases
but look we can make mansion irrelevant
again
all you have to do is engage in your
democracy do what democracies
do best
do what democracies do best
get the majority in power
that way the majority
can do things like i don't know govern
do you want the people
who are following the guy whose business
is under criminal indictment his chief
financial officer is under criminal
indictment he has to plea the fifth
today in his civil case against his
company otherwise he'll self-incriminate
and he'll be charged with crimes in that
state he's being investigated in the
state of georgia for election tampering
he's was just raided by the fbi for
felonies possible felonies where he
stole classified documents from our
government
he's being under grand jury
investigation in dc for inciting a
violent insurrection to try to overthrow
our government
that's the person you want in charge of
your gas prices
that's the person you wouldn't charge of
your of your of your [ __ ] healthcare
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
anyone is in support of this bethune
should not have a finger
on government
anywhere not even all the way down to
the dog catcher for crying out loud
so it's up to you
it's up to you these pro-democracy
people
out there who believe in democracy who
believe in the institutions
of government that it's our government
it's us
we the people are the government
and if it's big government it's because
we want it
so
every single weekday i will be doing my
part and i will be sitting here yelling
and screaming into this microphone
bringing you the things that matter the
ways that you can get out there and
communicate with people in your
community
to engage in the ballot
to make sure
that our message is on point and we put
the gloves
well take the gloves off and really
fight the good fight of democracy
because that is what these fascists are
terrified of
they're terrified of we the people
they're terrified of democracy they're
terrified that the majority will stand
up against them
they're terrified of it
and
and you see it
no better
than this week
well last week too but this week as well
because it's been a great 10 days it's
been a great 10 days for democracy
and donald trump pleading pleading the
fifth this morning in his civil case
against him in the state of new york
doesn't help him
it doesn't help him it only proves that
he's in a corner here that's all that it
proves
just like when
they all took the fifth for the january
6th select committee you think that
helped them
you think that was that was advisable to
do that as far as the court of public
opinion because folks that's what
matters in 2022 with this midterm we
have the chance
to indict
convict
and punish these fascists with our vote
with our democracy we are the jury
that's what we get to do
so
make sure to subscribe right here at the
tony michaels podcast you do not want to
miss an episode
every single weekday monday through
friday noon eastern 11 central nine
pacific on youtube twitter and twitch
and simulcasting from the mice touch
facebook page also follow us on twitter
we're at hump day
and that means in a few days we will
have bonehead of the week
so you want to go vote on twitter at
tonymichaelspod or you can vote right
here on youtube
either place also download every single
episode
of the tony michaels podcast on apple
spotify google your favorite directory
while you're there on the directory
downloading the episode
be sure to leave us a review
be sure to leave us a review on the
directory there we would much appreciate
that
we love having you here
and our audience is growing and growing
and growing so do us a favor share us
with your family with your friends
like-minded folks
you know you can even share us with your
trump family i don't care i'd love to
have trumpers listen to me
i would love for them to listen to me
so do me a favor do what you can we need
to spread this message
far and wide before the midterms
you know just don't just for me do it
for the midas touch network you know we
have a lot of great personalities a lot
of great shows here on the midas touch
network
we go live two hours every single day we
have the midas touch podcast which airs
two times a week on on
mondays and thursdays we have legal af
that airs on wednesdays and saturdays to
break down the legal issues that are
happening we also have lee mcgowan
politics girl bringing to you on
thursdays we have kremlin file we have
dr hassan
the list goes on and on and on
we have all the great creators over on
the youtube channel so don't forget to
stay tuned to the midas touch network
it is super important
for you to stay up to date they have so
many videos going on
at a moment's notice for breaking news
to bring it to you in video form so that
you can share it around
that's the purpose share it around to
your family your friends
it is super important that they see this
news through a filter that is not the
mainstream media
we must we must spread this message
and we will win
i have no doubt that there are plenty of
people out there in this country that
are sick and tired of trumpism kansas
and them telling the legislator there in
kansas to [ __ ] off when it comes to
taking roy their rights
i believe this country is ready to
engage
and i believe they're ready to engage
and i think we should engage them
fully politicize this at every single
measure
a lot of people oh tony that's oh that's
oh that's what they do that's what they
do
were you gonna stand back and let them
do it and let them win you're going to
let them take away your [ __ ]
democracy because that's what they want
to do i don't know if you've been
listening i don't know if you saw the
the nuremberg rally that they had down
in texas but their plan is to take away
your democracy your their plans take
away your [ __ ] vote
your way of life that you have that nice
little town that nice little school
all that little the church that you have
they want to take all that away
and they want to rebuild it in their
name and their white christian
nationalism that's what they want
is that what you want
well we have to do something about it we
can't just stand back and watch them
take over and turn this into a fascist
state we have to make a statement
and that is what this is about is making
a statement we cannot plead the fifth on
this midterm
we cannot plead the fifth on this
midterm
we shall not abstain
we have to make our voices heard
yes we should win
i think we can get the 54-55 in the
senate to be honest with you
if we engage heavily and we go out there
and we do the work that democracies do
and we get people aware because that's
the key here folks
the key is we must make every person who
is able to vote aware of what the issue
is
they're taking away women's rights
they're making sure to stoke fear by
getting as many weapons on the street as
they possibly can
they're making you afraid of the
government by thanking the if you steal
classified documents from the white
house by god they could come and knock
down your damn no [ __ ] sherlock
no [ __ ] they can come and [ __ ] knock
down your door if you illegally took
classified documents and property that
is not yours from the white house they
most certainly can come knock down your
door that's not big government that's
just
enforcing the law
law and order i thought they were the
party of law and order they never have
been
we have to tie them did the fun defund
the police remember that remember in
2020 like democrats want to get rid of
the police
they're doing that right now tie it to
him
when you're talking to your uncle earl
who loves trump he was like yeah
democrats they just want to defund the
police back the blue they want to defund
the police that way we we can have
antifa running around just tell them hey
man if they [ __ ] if they defund the fbi
like these fascists want there'll be
antifa everywhere
you're gonna let the republican party
defund the police so there's antifa
everywhere uncle earl you're out of your
mind
we have to stick this to them
they are the ones who wanted to adopt
all this fascism
so tie a trench chain around their ankle
put the block of fascism
on the end of the chain and throw them
into the ocean [ __ ] them
it's time we fight like we like we like
democracy
like we want democracy
and i here in the tony michaels podcast
i will be intolerant
of intolerance
you goddamn better well believe that
that i will be intolerant of intolerance
and if your goal is to take away rights
from other people in this country uh
nope not gonna tolerate that [ __ ] i am
not gonna tolerate your intolerance to
say that a woman's body is not her body
[ __ ] you that she does not have the
right to her bodily autonomy that
someone does not have the right to their
vote that someone does not have the
right to to to
to cross state lines to receive a
medical procedure [ __ ] you
equity inequality is what democracy
delivers and it's difficult it's hard
it's inch by inch by inch by inch
and sometimes we
inadvertently elect fascists and they
try to roll back our work
but we must continue this work of
democracy we must continue to fight it
is worth every single inch we fight
every single inch we progress to more
equality and more equity for all people
no matter their race their gender their
sex
whatever it is
we have to be intolerant of intolerance
and we must we must stand our ground
for democracy
you can do that by listening every
single weekday right here on youtube
twitter twitch for two full hours
at noon eastern
11 central nine pacific
on youtube twitter and twitch
and simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page don't forget to subscribe
to our youtube channel that helps us out
a lot
everyone stick around we're gonna go
there's a lot of stuff to get to this
morning with this fifth amendment thing
and more news about the search and
seizure and raid
at mar-a-lago stick around don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker convoy
there's tammy
by the time we reached dc we was 50
strong in number some patriots ran out
of gas along the way
we got plenty of slim jims
skull
near run out natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
circle the city again
here's
bob
dear bob
i'm fixing to send you some more of them
doritos you like the red bag not the
live loving blue one
in your absence i discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and i
even seen my cousin brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
ears
tammy
[ __ ] em
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around through the
break
appreciate having you here on youtube
twitter twitch every single weekday
monday through friday noon eastern 11
central nine pacific and simulcasting
the midas touch facebook page hello
everybody happy happy hump day
glad to have you there's a lot of new
listeners out there
and it gets more and more every single
week so we appreciate having you here
and if you're a new listener just know
that we love having you here on the tony
michaels podcast brought to you on the
midas touch network
have you guys been following this holy
moly there's a lot of breaking news in
the last few weeks and the minus touch
network has been doing a bang-up job
all of our favorite personalities
over there on the minus touch network
so stick around here for two hours every
single weekday monday through friday as
we bring you
the politics that you need to know
every single weekday
and i i have to say my favorite part of
the week is bonehead of the week that is
one of my favorite segments like the
[ __ ] list roundup that we do here every
single day on the podcast that excites
me a lot
because i like to tick through
what is important some of the video
on twitter we surf the tweety tweets and
the trendy trends
all the time but the bone end of the
week oh man that just really gets me i
love the bonehead of the week i love
mocking these morons
these boneheads it's fantastic and boy
boy are we poised to have some great
boneheads this week
now here's what happens to all for all
the new listeners out there for bonehead
of the week we put a poll out on twitter
every single week normally on thursday
evening at tony michael's pot go follow
us on twitter you can also follow us
here on youtube and you can vote right
here on youtube
but every single week we put out a poll
for bonehead of the week where you vote
you decide
and me and my great co-host and
executive producer gabe sanchez break
down the bonehead of the week every
single friday in the second hour
a bonehead of the week
so don't forget to join us on fridays
also the great part about bonehead of
the week is we cut that out of the show
and we air that on all the directories
you can download bonehead of the week on
sundays
on apple spotify google wherever you
download your podcast your favorite spot
to download them you can download
bonehead of the week every single sunday
in and of itself we also put out a best
of
every single saturday so you get a best
of on saturday and the bonehead of the
week on sunday which means you can
download the tony michaels broadcast
seven
days
a week every single day every one of
them
every single one of them so don't forget
to like subscribe go to
thetonymichaels.com where you can find
your great the great tony michael merch
the [ __ ] hats the gabe sanchez merch
over there
please go give us some support over
there if you can
there's also a link at the top of the
page if you'd like to support us even
more
we'd appreciate that a whole lot
i think i think there's a lot of stuff
to get to in the news today and we're
already at the bottom of the first hour
so let's do this let's go through the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
thanks for sticking around for the [ __ ]
list roundup where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends we
go surfing folks
we surf twitter
right here on the tony michaels podcast
every single weekday
and boy is there a lot of stuff in the
news today with this fifth amendment
you know donald trump for in the 2016
campaign
went on and on and on and on and on on
and on and on and on and more on and on
and on and on about the fifth amendment
and hillary clinton or someone else
taking the fifth amendment which
everyone has the right to the fifth
i i don't operate the fifth most of the
time i
i yell i'm screaming to the microphone a
lot
but everyone in this country has the
right to the fifth amendment you
actually do have the right not to
self-incriminate yourself that is the
right that you have and basically what
that means is if you have committed
crimes or think you've committed crimes
you don't have to tell someone that
under a legal deposition
you can keep your mouth shut they have
to prove it in other words
but it really is kind of funny
it really is kind of funny because we
are we should have a a in this country
you should be innocent until proven
guilty that is what we should have
that's a standard that should bear in
the court of law now that is not the
standard that we have in the court of
public opinion unfortunately the court
of public opinion does not give a [ __ ]
does not give a [ __ ] about the law it
just doesn't it doesn't give two shits
and this morning
this morning what we need to do in the
court of public opinion is show the
court of public opinion the evidence
of donald trump
knowing that if someone pleads the fifth
that they are guilty
of what they are being asked that is
what weak the evidence we can give the
court a public opinion
you see how this works you see how the
right has always been successful at this
they c they've never been scared to do
these kind of things i'm not scared to
do these kind of things are you scared
to do these kind of thing i would be
willing to show the the most staunch
staunchest trump supporter a video of
him saying yeah pleading the fifth means
you're a criminal
that means you're guilty
i i mean i i would love to sit him down
in the chair and show him over and over
and over and over and over again almost
hypnotized him into believing that
donald trump is the criminal he actually
is
i mean they've been hypnotized the
opposite direction
why why not do it
in favor of the truth
so
what we must do
is to continue
to show the court of public opinion the
evidence
that the gqp the republican party or
what once was what's left of it there
isn't much left of this republican party
are nazis they're fascists
they're american nazis fascism in a
manga hat they're white christian
nationalists jesus christ they're
calling himself that they're [ __ ]
domestic terrorists and they're calling
themselves that we're domestic
terrorists you goddamn right
so let's tag him with it sure let's give
the evidence to the court of public
opinion so let's start by surfing the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
let's see here let's go right down to
the the
the trump videos of course um
midas dutch had this video this is not a
new video
and that's how you know the court of
public opinion is not it has not quite
got it yet and we need to keep pounding
this drum
minus touch made this video a while back
trump is guilty this isn't like a new
video this morning
this is a video they did a while ago
when he started to talk at the fifth and
his family was taking the fifth for
different depositions
but watch this trump is guilty it will
stay relevant for a long long time
the mob takes it
if you're innocent why are you taking
the fifth second why fast
house probe into january 6 alex jones
told his podcast audience he pleaded the
fifth almost 100 times have you seen
what's going on in front of congress
fifth amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment mr clark intends to invoke the
fifth amendment privilege against
self-incrimination another lawyer
involved in this scheme to flip the
election results lawyer john eastman he
too is going to take the fifth taking
the fifth i think it's disgraceful trump
organization's accounting firm now says
nearly a decade worth of financial
statements can no longer be relied upon
and they cannot represent donald trump
anymore his son eric trump invoked his
right against self-incrimination in
response to more than 500 questions
fifth amendment
ah president trump and two of his
children must answer questions under
oath that from a judge in new york today
it's possible he will take the fifth
take the fifth take the fifth he won't
say anything this is like watergate
only it's worse
he's guilty that's why he's taking the
fifth
i mean that's what trump says right i
don't know i'm just i'm just going by
what he said
i i don't know i mean it could be don't
you think the mob takes it don't you
think
and the mob takes the fifth why wouldn't
the mob take the fifth i mean they're
guilty as [ __ ]
but it's their right to not
self-incriminate
see in the in the united states of
america we have certain rights
now they want to take away those rights
right they want to take away those
rights quickly so if you want to keep
the fifth amendment and you want to keep
the ability for trump and trump the
trump crime family
to be able to invoke the fifth
then you better go vote that's all i'm
saying if you want that right because i
i believe that's a that's a right that
we must have uh
speaking of uh
rights oh everyone's yelling and
screaming about the uh mar-a-lago raid
uh this is brent therihune we've had
brent on the uh on the show before and
he does great videos this is
oh this is great satire there's nothing
better than this political satire it's
got almost a million views now um this
uh
this game have you have you have you
seen this video from brent it's
hilarious yeah if you watch this oh my
god so the part that got me in stitches
is is the reference to the back to the
future in biff that's the part that
really oh my god man i couldn't even
finish the goddamn video i couldn't
finish the video i was
does an amazing job of of pulling random
uh
references to like he's he does what i
do in some videos that will do like
easter eggs
yeah yeah they'll be easter eggs but
also just like random word association
like right you're making these
conspiracy theory connections that no
one would ever really think of but it
sounds so ridiculous and it's so funny
in the moment too especially because
when he does these rants like he's
playing you know he's playing a
character that seems like he is that
person right um which he does a
marvelous job like he's yeah i i we we
talked about this with our interview
anyone who wants to go watch the
interview just go to the youtube channel
um it's on the interviews uh playlist
there with brent um where we interview
him it's it's hilarious we had a great
time we should i should have i should uh
send him a message to say hey come back
on the show and at least talk about this
video for a few minutes because it's
hilarious uh but he does such a great
job with his character because it's so
believable and a lot of people still
believe it even though he's been doing
these videos for a long time right you
know it's it's kind of worn off a bit a
lot of people have caught on but um but
he's still so believable when he does it
uh so let's watch let's watch the video
here where he's he's very upset he's
very upset that they did they did an
injustice and raided mar-a-lago because
trump is possibly committed crimes let's
listen so i just seen on fox news that
they finally did it
they raided mar-a-lago
you can't just go storming stuff without
permission what do you think this is
some kind of government building
where a minor dust-up occurred i don't
think so
this is illegal this is the home slash
golf course last resort of the greatest
american never walked the face of this
flat earth and just the just the thought
of the fbi busting in makes me sick
kicking in the door
scaring eric off his fleshlight don jr
probably dumping powder down the toilet
like he's carrying from good fellas them
agents uh ripping up
couch cushions flipping over tables
whispering in their wrist
like oh mulder and scully to president
brandon the eagle has landed i repeat
the the eagle has landed
no no sir this is not your alexa
this is the fbi
just hand the phone to somebody else
but but i digest
it makes me sick and then you can rest
assured that i've already written in not
the fbi on all my back of blue stickers
you asked me we should defund the fbi
they don't need all them windbreakers
they don't need all them windbreakers
to make matters worse
they broke into his safe
probably taking his sports almanac and
whatever else he's got in there well if
they break into his safe they damn sure
can break into my safe and you're safe
proven
how unsafe these people actually are
it's not safe
well you know what you go ahead and keep
it up president brandon you wicked
despicable evil mastermind who's also
got dementia you do your worst because
unlike josh hawley these colors don't
run
these
oh my god
oh thank you brent for the uh
oh for the the relief here from the
insanity because that that's really what
we need is is the relief from the
insanity the best part about
brent's character that he does the trump
supporter that he does
and really i don't even know if he's a
trump supporter as much as he just you
know he'll buy anything that the that
the fox news or the media might tell him
right right that's that's the character
here it's not really a trump fan or a
trump supporter it's just someone who
absolutely buy anything that is told to
them right
but he does a fantastic job because it's
totally believable and and we talk about
it in the interview so everyone should
go check out the interview it's been a
couple months ago i think that uh that
we interviewed brent and we talked we
talked about his content we talked about
how how he develops those videos and how
he developed the character so go check
that interview out on the youtube
channel don't forget to subscribe while
you're on the youtube channel looking
for that video because here's the thing
is that you just go to the interview
playlist we have a playlist with the
interviews
in it speaking of that i need to get the
um
texas paul interview that we did and
rachel bit of coffee yeah that we just
did i need to get them up there someone
needs to make some um some nice little
art for that i don't know okay well
maybe maybe we'll put that on the lid
maybe we'll put that on the list
yeah well you just tell me what uh
[Music]
we gotta we got another
speaking of interviews we got another
great interview coming up uh on monday
interviewing another comedian and he
does a lot of political comedy and uh
he's very very very outspoken against
charlie kirk so make sure to pay
attention on monday because we have a
great interview coming up if you're a
charlie kirk hater which i know our
audiences
[ __ ] hate that guy i mean i'm not
scared to say it i hate that son of a
[ __ ] i hate that [ __ ] yeah i
mean i you're allowed you're allowed to
have those kind of visceral reactions
towards people who try to overthrow our
government i mean i just i think and who
spew this homophobic racist you know
just nonsense just this fascism and and
actually hold a hold up a student
conference
down in florida as a thin veil of of a
nazi rally where actual nazis show up at
your at your little conference and
they're marching outside and you're
you're proud of it so
i i don't like nazis i'm just not a fan
and charlie kirk is a nazi so if you
want to watch a comedian
and we we go through a very famous clip
of charlie kirk getting owned getting
his ass owned on abortion so if you want
to watch that come on monday well
actually just come here every single
weekday yeah monday through friday noon
eastern 11 central nineveh monday
specifically yeah we have
self-proclaimed charlie kirk the
biologist you know yeah gets a little
feature in the interview yeah he gets he
gets he gets a little he gets had let's
just say that let's just so what do you
make gabe of the fifth this morning are
you surprised i'm not surprised are you
surprised well people should know no no
people should know that that donald
trump he took the fifth back in
as early as it's been documented in 1990
when he was during his divorce
deposition so
people were like oh i can't believe he
took the fifth really the guy will take
the fifth whenever he can right he will
plead the fifth to get out whatever
trouble whatever paying someone uh any
sort of responsibility for something he
will 100 percent take the fifth whenever
he can
yeah whenever it's possible never is
convenient for him yeah here's the
report on fox news
of course they kind of breathe over to
them talk about the middle class audits
okay wow
crazy oh yeah okay well let's let's see
what they say about the fifth amendment
here
and
i think the most important thing to
point out here when you read the
statement when they read the statement
of donald trump you can tell this was
written by his lawyers which i think is
very significant who as david lee miller
was telling us just before the president
spoke president biden that president
trump was doing
you had to specify oh yo well you got on
fox news you really got to distinguish
though she was like president president
biden now it's remember it's former
two-time impeached president trump
disgraced yeah
wannabe dictator
right you know maybe not foreign fifth
the fifth president the fifth president
we just we just fifth amendment his ass
out of the history yeah i think that's a
good idea we could just use the fifth on
the history that he was actually
president that's not a bad idea you know
this brings me to a to a subject that i
was talking about yesterday
because a lot of people have a lot of
confusion about these presidential
records
the presidential record act came after
richard nixon yeah yeah because nixon
was trying to steal a lot of [ __ ] right
he was trying to steal records he was
trying to destroy records so they came
up with that presidential record act
after that after that the whole white or
watergate scandal right
now
the other thing too that a lot of people
don't understand is that those records
the reason why it's so important is
because they're our records
they're not they're not the white house
records they're not donald trump's
records or barack obama george w bush
they're our records so what we do what
we do as a government is we generally
set up
in most cases set up a presidential
library where those records can live in
a national archive right one's the ones
that can be publicly shown
well even the ones that can't be
publicly shown are held at those
libraries they hold them there that is
where they are archived and and we build
a government building we have a place
and we have people who curate them who
store them who make sure when they need
to be released like when when it is time
to release stuff like you're saying that
is held in secret for so many years they
start to release this like we we watched
the knicks and a lot of the nixon tapes
some lbj tapes be released in the last
10 years um you know now that we're away
from their presidencies that stuff is
starting to become public and the
archive of the of their presidential
library which is a government entity
it's out again it may have the
president's name on it whoever the
president is but that's our archive
of their
time in our office
right that's what that is
and we give the national archives money
to go build
in the federal government we give them
money by our representation
to go build those archives so we have
our records stored
properly for history and for again as an
archive of our office that that person
whoever's name is on the building
held our office
now it gets me thinking
like what kind of [ __ ] coloring book
factory are we going to build for donald
trump
uh
well
i mean it's kind of a residential
library or is it like just it just is
called the trump archives like
crime archives yeah i think well i think
one
hands down i guarantee trump will try to
build the library at mar-a-lago
for sure
wait when you think there's gonna be a
library at mar-a-lago i think he's gonna
try to argue
how either one
they build a library because he will he
will 100 percent get um get his
followers his cult to to pay for the
library now well you're seeing this is
like another steve bannon build a wall
type thing i i think so so what i think
will happen is he will try to fundraise
to build a library right as soon as they
we've established that president trump
is either not gonna run
or he is unsuccessful in running if he
does run you know if this whole like
going to jail thing doesn't work out
getting a felony preventing him doesn't
work out he will try to grip he might
even try to grift and say we want to
build this presidential library before
they try to stop me before the woke left
democrats try to stop me your president
he will say let's fundraise to build a
library and then he will say oh well you
know what we couldn't get it done in
time so what we're going to say is this
quarter
of the mar-a-lago or the whole thing
is deemed the presidential library for
trump and let's say he doesn't even get
that the most he will get is a pop-up
book that'll be on right next to the
plot of ivana right well that's what
maybe that's what he does is bedminster
is now a cemetery maybe he turns it into
a government property to get even even
more tax benefits exactly tries to open
up there and then he starts charging
people to come in even though they're
supposed to be free you know like he
will make money off this stuff whenever
he can i can't imagine
i guarantee he probably also charges
people to see ivana's uh plot well
that's possible it has a gate there and
they gotta have uh money maybe he'll
even have like a little carnival ride
next to it like i'm like a one of those
uh you know scrambler type things oh i
was just thinking to be one of those
little like horsies you know with the
ones oh yeah
and you put in a quarter you know
but except you have to feed it like five
dollars for the quarters because that's
all it accepts
that's what you would do
and they're like oh if you want change
you can exchange it here but we'll
charge you a fee to run your your your
dollar into it's 20 it's 20 exactly to
get the change that you need for that
and they're not oh that's a good deal
i'm saying oh wow yeah
[ __ ] morons but no i'm serious i i
don't actually think because if you
think about where donald trump's library
build it be in new york city that's
where he's from right do you think new
york city is going to let him i don't
know that no way no [ __ ] way [ __ ]
way so i mean he gets that approved i
actually think what because we have to
store these records somewhere that's the
whole point that i'm trying to make is
these records have to be stored
somewhere and and generally speaking
the norm when you have a normal
non-criminal president um you generally
build them a library to house their
records from the time that they were in
our presidential office like that's
that's the norm right but we're not
normal times right and everyone the
media keeps saying this is unprecedented
did you see the washington post they're
trending this morning because they're
like oh my god the doc democracy dies in
darkness and they act like the fbi
raiding a criminal's home in florida
because he committed [ __ ] obvious
crimes and he won't [ __ ] give the
records back and there's obvious crimes
they're being committed that the fbi
going in and getting the [ __ ] that was
criminally taken is somehow [ __ ]
obscure this is nonsense that's actually
nice so that's so weird i would think
that uh which totally i guess goes
against the whole theory that bezos is
like directing what the headlines are at
the washington post no i mean every
single one of their narrative has always
crashed man i mean this morning this
morning another narratives crash about
[ __ ] inflation inflation is finally
backing off i mean oh
yeah i mean there's signs there are
signs of no recession
i did that i did that yeah right other
than other than the actual recession
that the fed is going to draw us in by
making money more expensive for the
middle class and working people i mean
there's there's cause to be concerned
that that's that they're going to force
us into a recession by making money cost
more but i mean but i mean the demand is
there and i really think that it speaks
well not just
of joe biden himself but of his
administration here gabe because we
talked a lot about uh elon musk not
buying twitter
and all this justice the gas prices how
that's all nonsense
it was always nonsense it was always a
supply problem because the world told
putin to go [ __ ] himself and he can keep
his oil i mean the pandemic happens so
we're still having the effects of that
last year in the beginning of this year
i mean this all this stuff was happening
and and not just biden but the
administration
kept their cool
right they kept their cool they're like
no this is obvious some obvious things
that's happening no matter what
the media is saying no matter how the
media is painting it we're going to keep
our cool we're going to keep going we're
going to keep steady here and i think it
really speaks to the american people's
choice when the american people voted 81
million people voted against trump yeah
and they decided that they wanted
someone in government who wasn't just
gonna [ __ ] you know take a
sledgehammer to everything and keep
their cool because that's really what
happened during the trump presidency is
every little thing was a [ __ ] crisis
every little thing was chaos right i
mean jesus
remember remember when they were gonna
ban
e-cigarettes like yeah everyone was
freaking out there was there was which
maybe there was cause for concern there
most certainly was but they freaked out
and they were gonna ban them 19 children
get slaughtered and evolved they're like
no you can't take our guns i mean it
just it doesn't make any sense i mean
they don't they do not make that is the
the slogan of the gop we don't make any
sense also we're pedophiles
like that is who they are is that an
actual is it did you find that somewhere
yeah i think i mean they call themselves
domestic viewers can you imagine if they
at the next nazi rally they do that we
are all pedophiles
i hope they do i hope they think that
that is some sort of tongue-in-cheek
joke and it's like you're like haha this
is funny that we call ourselves domestic
terrorists i mean we call ourselves
pedophiles right well marjory taylor
green was already accusing people of
being on the on the right of being
pedophiles who were voting for
um what is this recent no no no this was
uh let me hear them uh yeah finally
let's play the rest of this clip while
you're looking for it because i want to
get to the fifth amendment here how the
statement that trump made and that's why
i'm playing this fox news clip i
wouldn't generally play a clip like this
but the statement that he makes and how
they frame it up is [ __ ] hilarious
for today was giving a deposition there
is news there and we go back to david
lee miller now hi david lee he was
giving a deposition so they don't
actually frame it up at all he frames it
up a bit watch how he frames it up
hi dana the headline this hour is that
the former president is pleading the
fifth rather than giving testimony in a
deposition regarding a civil case a
civil case now listen he he has to go he
has to actually give some facts here
which is is really detrimental this is
why they're playing it
at at 10 35 eastern not in the morning
or in the afternoon or evening but watch
brought by the state attorney general
latisha james mr trump released a
statement uh soon after he entered the
offices of the state attorney general
that said in part and i quote i did
nothing wrong which is why after five
years of looking the federal state and
local governments together with the fake
news media have found nothing okay so he
he obviously dictated that part right
yeah yeah that's because i think this is
the push and shove here apparently he
has been prepping with his attorneys for
several days maybe even weeks is what
someone oh
he's been prepping ever since uh ivana
just happened to fall down the stairs
right they they've been prepping for
this deposition and they've been
prepping him and obviously they came to
the conclusion that this guy cannot do
this if he says any if he starts talking
he is [ __ ] and we are [ __ ] like so
so they come up with the statement about
the fifth amendment but of course he's
got to get his digs in so his digs are
on the front of the statement let's
listen to the back of the statement
it goes on to say and i quote
accordingly under the advice of my
counsel and for all of the above reasons
i declined to answer the questions under
the rights and privileges afforded to
every citizen under the united states
now fox news even knew which part was
him and which part wasn't him they broke
it up
they broke it up right and accordingly
they knew he wouldn't use the word
out loud or in a statement or in a tweet
or in a post or whatever it is
accordingly
never would they use it never would but
also for someone who is innocent right
again this the guy said
you know why would you why would you
plead the fifth if you're innocent right
uh you know the mob takes or takes the
fifth right these are these are things
that he has said in the ha in the past
now despite the fact that he has also
pleaded the fifth since 1990 or before
that as well
this is one of those moments where it's
like if you really are innocent like you
claim to be you said they've you know
the fake news media and they tried to
come after me for this and that and they
found five years of nothing after five
years they were unable to find anything
he believes he is innocent even though
he knows he's guilty
if he really was innocent then he should
have no problem to come forward and
answer the questions right right if he
really was innocent he should have no
problem
going before the january 6 committee and
answering the questions doing a
deposition he says he wants equal time
there they will give him a whole [ __ ]
slot that's right he wants to give
if he wants to speak they will say you
know what [ __ ] we're going to just
like stop everyone that we have coming
up and we will just have don it'll just
become the donald trump january 6th show
if he really is innocent and he says
he's innocent and he really believes
that then put your money where your
mouth is [ __ ] can you imagine
if liz cheney
adam schiff
and jamie raskin got to got to depose
in front of the cameras for 11 hours
like
oh my god dude i would stream that all
day long oh yeah oh my god [ __ ] yes
let's do that 11 hours of donald trump
being questioned by liz cheney adam
schiff
and jamie raskin oh [ __ ] yeah let's do
that
oh my god that would be fantastic listen
to the rest of this clip though because
he really he gets into the reporting of
why he's there to posing and why he uh
has to plea the fifth here
and what's even better about it is it
kind of cut him off when he starts
saying that [ __ ] watch
constitution and again dana underscoring
the fact that this is a civil deposition
mr trump
and his company are facing possible
financial penalties one reason perhaps
he decided to plead the fifth so there
he's like he's very careful here he's
being very careful because he wants to
stay on the air here for his reporting
listen when he gets into more facts here
about this the uh district attorney in
new york has a parallel his own
investigation which is criminal in
nature that is taking place
which he kind of brushes over that it's
criminal no no no no no the organization
that he is going in and giving civil
deposition for today and he pled the
fifth for is criminally indicted it's
not a criminal i mean there is a
criminal investigation but they are
indicted they are indicted with the cfo
he kind of breezes over that a bit right
right right they they can't even put up
with breezing over this these fans and
it is very possible that the district
attorney would be able to access this
deposition and use it against mr trump
if he goes forward with any criminal
prosecution so at this hour we
understand the former president so there
it is there's the uh
there's the
the facts
of the reason why he pled the fifth gabe
the reason why
it is not because he has the right to
and he doesn't want to self-incriminate
it's because he's a [ __ ] criminal and
he runs a criminal organization that is
currently under indictment criminal
indictment in the state where he is
giving the civil deposition and anything
he says anything and i'm sure that's
where the attorneys were trying to prep
him and work with him and it just wasn't
working like nope you are definitely if
you say anything but fifth fifth fifth
fifth you are definitely going to be in
big ass also i also guarantee that when
the questions were asked they're you
know
you know i don't know how this works in
terms of i've never been deposed for
something or had to plead the fifth uh
because i'm not a criminal but uh
you know in those moments like we saw
some of the depositions where there's
like a little bit of a
to the lawyer or the lawyer looking at
them to be like kind of a signal like i
don't know if a an attorney can like tap
you or you know just like or if that
seems to be leading anyway they're
sitting next to you if you watch it
watch like uh patsy bologna right you
watch some of those depositions from the
g because he took executive privilege
which was basically the fifth right
right if you watch and even even the
short clips of michael flynn general
michael flynn that traitor uh taking the
fifth
they're really sitting really close to
their attorney and the attorney has
turned towards them and has their hands
on the table and you know they're kind
of they kind of move their hand or
they're giving a sign that hey
easy on this question here right right
and then again they make eyebrows
because the other thing like you know
like you're saying like if he doesn't
say anything but the fifth he'll be
[ __ ] but we know for a fact that when
trump talks he will go off script he'll
have something on the teleprompter he'll
go off script he'll blame the
teleprompter like he did about you know
1775 revolutionary army had airports
okay we'd have airports airplanes until
the 1900s and use them until the early
night hey gabe gabe that's fake news uh
all right but what i'm saying
is that even though this guy will read
off a teleprompter he'll go [ __ ]
the person who who writes like [ __ ] it
like he just went off script again and i
guarantee
that that is where leticia james and
everyone else who is in that room
deposing him knows exactly for a fact
how to [ __ ] poke and prod to get him
to be like what right and then
i think the obvious thing here is is
that tish james has the evidence
and they were gonna ask questions based
on that evidence and and probably the
attorneys knew and through discovery
what the what the attorney general had
right right and there and he and they
were doing like practice runs like fake
depositions to try to ask him questions
and every time they would try to ask the
questions in the way that they thought
the attorney general would because of
the evidence that they know she has he
probably went off on tangents they're
like nope now you can't say that you
can't say that and he's like that's what
i want to say like okay well exactly and
also i probably guaranteed that once
they started asking questions and it got
too difficult for him to like
think or just answer he would throw up
his arms go like this
and then he'd be like nap time no it's
time for nap time oh someone needs to
change my diaper
i'm hangry hmm you know and i i'm
positive that once once the questions
got tough which would probably be right
out of the [ __ ] gate outside of the
fact of can you verify that you are
named donald j trump are you this person
great great great we know who you are we
have on the record now what the [ __ ]
were you doing you know he's like oh oh
i you know they're like nope nope nope
well he would just justify his crimes
which is the problem that's what he does
every time he would just justify his
crimes that's the whole is a perfect
call it's the perfect phone call it's
the best phone call ever and he said
that about the youtube and then he's
probably saying that about the georgia
phone call and then i guarantee he'd
probably attack leticia james or whoever
else is in the room at personal attacks
and be like you nasty woman you're right
right right you woke better like and
again it's on the record right and this
is him
here's the question and then his answer
is just an immediate overreaction right
uh it's like anyone else online it's
like a walking overreaction well yeah
totally but it's it is that whole party
all of maga whenever you're like hey
here's the fact and this person says no
it's not and you say here's another
source that says this is the fact and
they go no it's not and you say okay
fine here's the third source to say this
is the fact and they go you're ugly and
it's like what did we what are we doing
here that is the exact what trump does
is exactly what he taught his party to
do which is not actually look at facts
but go after uh personal attacks well he
also taught his children this he also
taught his children this which when
speaking of pleading the fifth how many
times does this get this guy's like a
record setting
uh to use the fifth amendment oh yeah
500 plus times yeah because i think he's
been deposed by in this civil case by
tis james like two times i think
is how many times he's been deposed um
and they sent eric in because eric
probably doesn't really know anything
you know it's just that [ __ ] they're
like he's so dumb right he doesn't know
that we're crying he couldn't he has no
clue that he couldn't even
get to it if he tried now the only
reason that eric trump would plead the
fifth is if he in a deposition was
accidentally
saying things that were true like um
like if anyone's seen conspiracy theory
with mel gibson like in that one like
he's coming up with these things and
then they the government ends up coming
after him because what he's what he
thinks or what he's made up in these
stories actually is true and it's his
government cover-up that's what i think
would happen here with eric trump like
he's some idiot well not idiot but like
everything he's in yeah he's a [ __ ]
idiot but an idiot who starts saying
some random things and answering the
questions and all of a sudden they
realize oh [ __ ] this is real stuff but
he's like oh yeah and he's like making
it all up in his head but turns out he's
actually telling the truth and that's
probably why they made him play the
fifth because they're like look dude
you're a bit of a wild card like we know
you're [ __ ] dumb and you really don't
have anything to say outside of
criticizing like biden's bicycle writing
but at the end of the day you might say
something because you overheard it
because you were like trying a little
peeping time into what your dad's
meetings were
so
he's crazy well let's listen to what
eric trump here has to say about the
raid
the rape mar-a-lago
i wonder what was in the safe that might
have been eric's i doubt anything but
let's listen
clinton and the clinton kind of dynasty
and machine who had outraged this by 5x
you better believe that somebody's hand
was you know was was guiding him through
um otherwise we would have stood a
chance in the world we had every
disadvantage maybe the one advantage
that we had
okay so they're interviewing him
about the rate at mar-a-lago
and he's talking about the 2016 election
this is par for the course too
they they lost the popular vote he won
the presidency the one win he's ever had
in his life that [ __ ] loser and he
and they can't stop talking about it
they can't stop and it's the emails
emails email [ __ ] which frankly if if
that's your your narrative around emails
and and his entire cult base is upset
still about emails then why aren't you
upset about what he's done with the
presidential records why
why you know the other funny part about
this whole thing is they keep saying
they never went and got hillary's server
and [ __ ] i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about they actually went to
their home and got that server you
people are boneheads right they actually
went to their home and got that server
and the reason why the fbi didn't kick
down their [ __ ] door the clinton's
door is because clinton's like yeah come
and get it yeah
when they were requested for the server
they let them come and get the server
i mean you know taking a page out of ted
cruz's book like come and get it yeah we
have like you know we have nothing to
hide come and get it right as opposed to
the republican party which is like whoa
whoa whoa why are you guys invading my
privacy why are you doing this uh right
now
no longer like you're looking for crimes
that i can't yeah yeah if you think the
fbi don't back the blue
right no i will not comply that is the
republican party so if there's ever a
crime right you've got marjorie taylor
green who's trying to defund the fbi
before anyone can actually let's be
clear they want to defund the police
yeah yeah
any law enforcement
this is what they're saying they want to
defund the police and we need to
politicize the [ __ ] out of that point
folks we need to tie that to them around
their ankles throw put that brick of
defund the police on the chain around
their ankles and throw them into the
ocean here we have to tie them to this
deep on the police we have to we have to
keep that narrative up that they want to
deep on the belief they don't want law
and order because law and order means
they go to jail let's listen to the rest
of this guy trying to not go to jail we
believe in god we believed in
family and we fought together as a
family um maybe that's the advantage we
had but i'm not sure if any advantage in
the world could have overcome
the odds that
we overcame and i really really do
believe that somebody was looking down
on him and why do people interview this
dumbass i don't know but again he's
trying to use god what does god have to
do with the religion
right now but here's the thing
christians and other religious people
evangelicals whoever that always want to
say oh it's god's plan it's god's plan
it's god's plan it's god's plan
i am successful because of god and it
was jesus who looked down on me and said
i want to give this man wealth and luck
right despite the fact that trump has
frauded people scam people not paid
people
uh was given money by his father didn't
start from you know a rags to riches
story you know
people who are wealthy and in in their
life whether it be money or luck or
whatever we'll always use that reason of
looks like somebody was just looking
down on me looks like god was just
thinking on about how i should be
uh successful
but what they don't say is when [ __ ]
happens
against them they don't say that's god's
will they go
that was satan that was saying that
right and you're like if it's all god's
will then god let it happen right god
let satan do that [ __ ] right
well you know there's a lot of videos um
because this fifth thing is not
is not surprising and yeah it's a big
story this morning uh because he's
taking the fifth amendment but it's
something that we knew he was gonna do
yeah uh even even after he's not having
a great week no well not a great we are
wednesday everyone everybody's been a
[ __ ] for him but every day this week so
far there's been something new that has
come out worst week ever yeah worst week
ever for trump i'm curious if we can go
five days straight right now we're three
days through well and really it's
because it's not a great uh date uh week
for trump it's a really bad week for the
gqp and then and the nazis that are the
the maga supporters the mongolidates
heather points it out here says record
levels of deflection and what about ism
on right-wing media since the raid at
mar-a-lago here's this quick sampling uh
so she put together a sample of some of
this [ __ ] let's listen ridiculous witch
hunt hillary clinton hillary clinton the
clinton foundation money was being
funneled by the millions into the
clinton foundation the 30 000 emails
that were erased and all that was okay
benghazi china russia 579 days without
justice for ashley babbitt diamonds are
being exchanged hunter biden doing crack
on tape hunter biden has his house been
raided covering up the laptop 20 million
illegals flooding across our border
sending our manufacturing jobs to china
paul paul is a senior i don't want them
to have hearings i don't want them to
clean the house i want them to start
prosecuting i want them to stop
[Laughter]
the ending there is uh appropriate
because that's literally what they sound
like yeah
but also the the idea that
uh these people republicans are always
like
hunter biden this hunter buying that
look i will say it right now on the show
hunter biden
if he is guilty like
look republicans need to shut the [ __ ]
up or move forward with actually
investigating and criminally charging
hunter biden for any crime i wish the
republican i wish the republican i wish
the republican christopher wray would
charge him if right you know but
as we know
it takes a good amount of evidence for
ray to say yep let's move forward with
that and a judge to say either a search
or an arrest warrant to say yes we
should do that you should go ahead and
execute that
but here republicans are saying oh
hundred bites in this hunter bite in
that their obsession their projection we
already know they can't move on from but
her emails and lock her up even though
she's you know she's uh testifying for
11 hours they take the servers they get
the emails that's the hilarious part
about it gabe is that they keep
complaining about the emails but the fbi
investigated that just like they're
investigating this [ __ ] presidential
records act like what are you people
talking about the only reason why they
had to go use a search warrant is
because his dumb ass was not
not participating in handing over the
[ __ ] that they needed that that was
that's our [ __ ] that our presidential
records the reason why hillary clinton
was never raided is because she gave the
fbi that stuff right she gave the state
department that step on request she she
said yeah here here's nothing to hide
there you go here's the [ __ ] they didn't
have to [ __ ] raid her that's the
point they didn't have to use other
means through a [ __ ] judge or a
magistrate
to get the [ __ ] they needed because they
were they were like nope i didn't do
anything wrong and now we know that the
emails was all a bunch of [ __ ] in
the first place right and with the
hundred and 100 and it's like yes he is
under investigation and republicans like
whoa let's do it
yeah okay [ __ ] if you guys can prove
it then do it right anyone who does
something bad should should pay the time
and or like do the time you know pay for
the crime that they committed so no one
on the on the left is saying oh no no no
no whoa whoa
back off 100 bride and it's like no
everyone is equal if you committed a
crime you need the time well but the
other thing too about the fbi and this
nonsense about her emails
is that somehow
somehow the fbi had no
didn't have throw a press conference
that republican
the republican he's a republican he was
in the bush administration he was under
john ashcroft james comey he was the fbi
director came out and gave press
conferences wrote letters to congress
that were leaked right before the
election like oh this is all political
and blah blah blah look if you i i would
like nothing more than merrick garland
to go out and destroy donald trump and
the republicans in this 2022 midterm but
he's not going to right he's not going
to do it merrick garland is not going to
come out in front of a microphone an
intentionally inject himself the fbi or
the doj into this election he's not
going to do it he's just going to do the
work that they have to do
and when they do it they're just going
to do it and
and go on with what the investigation is
they're not going to come out from the
microphone do what they did to hillary
clinton and that's really that's really
what i think that the trump supporters
are dying for
is that for for merrick garland to come
out and do that in front of a microphone
oh they want it because they can blame
right but it's like no no if it's gonna
happen
and i believe it will happen it will
happen after the midterms right and it's
gonna be a big i mean it's just gonna
happen one morning where he's charged by
the federal grand jury he came in they
got him at three in the morning trump
couldn't do his hair couldn't put his
makeup on he comes out
he's got [ __ ] snot coming down his
face because he's been crying yeah
guaranteed they do they do the same [ __ ]
they did to uh enrique tario which is to
get him out in his underwear do you
think we'll get like the jeffrey clark
and the john eastman videos i actually
think they won't do that to him no i
don't know if they will i mean like i
think i think what they're gonna do i
think what they're gonna do is they're
to give them a chance to
to sell surrender uh if he is indicted
to be arraigned on that chart whatever
the charge or charges are they're going
to give them a chance um to do that now
i don't yeah they i i think that that in
georgia and georgia oh my god she's
going to lay the hammer down [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
of letting himself surrender they'll do
the perp walk in georgia for state
charges but but um you know here we go
uh with uh you posted this speaking of
crimes
and committing crimes there's this
document that's come out it's a law
and someone signed it into law and uh
let's see yours 2015 2018 i don't know
who is the president who is the
president of 2018 you remember yeah it
was joe biden yeah i think so it was
dark brandon who was the uh president
2018 you pointed this out trump is
literally
his own worst enemy uh jeff yarborough
um he says
so when did the doj start treating
removal of classified documents like a
felony anyways the answer to that
question when president trump signed a
2018 law making it a felony now down
here you can see section 202 increased
penalty for un unauthorized removal now
this is this is important removal and
retention of classified documents and
materials uh section
1924a of title 18 u.s code is amended by
striking one year and inserting five
years so they change it to a felony here
um because before that you remember the
the very very famous case of david
petraeus
general david patricia
yeah yeah
so he obviously he's a he's a high
ranking general he had he had he had uh
security clearance to have classified
documents but the problem was is he was
being interviewed by a person for a
biography
and this person who was interviewing for
him for the biography he ended up having
an affair with her
that wasn't the legal problem the legal
problem is he left some of these
documents in her possession right so he
gave them to a third party because
before before that well during that time
just the removal and retention
of classified documents wasn't really a
crime it was a misdemeanor but they
really didn't charge because what they
would do is they found out about this
they would go to the person and they
would give them a chance to give it back
like oh i'm sorry you know yeah because
sometimes this could probably happen
unintentionally that's why it was a
misdemeanor now it's a felony um i don't
know what law was this in is this the
law that they that they did for the the
statues or whatever what what law was
this that they didn't uh
i
don't recall i'd have to look that up
further but he signed it he said but he
signed it yeah yeah he was like now
we're going from one year to five years
right we're gonna make what i'm about to
do in two years a felony let's like
and i and i i almost like either in the
moment he was like yeah i'm gonna punish
these [ __ ] and make it a felony
or
he signed it didn't know what he was
signing because we know he doesn't read
the d he never read the daily briefs he
always would like get someone to give
him like the tl dr which he would
probably miss stuff he wouldn't read the
most you know news he would get would be
from fox news in terms of what they were
reporting news yeah news which became
like a cycle of them saying something
him saying something them saying
something him saying something and over
and over again until like it's just you
know a game of telephone
and
for this
yeah he either signed it knew what it
was signed it didn't know what it was or
he signed it knew what it was and then
you know
boom totally forgot about it because
that was four years ago
a lot of stuff's on his mind he can only
really focus on what's in front of him
so he probably forgot the fact that he
signed this i was like yeah let's make
it a felony [ __ ] it
yeah well yeah well i mean and the other
thing too
here is that
i believe that there's more to this than
he just possessed these records and
wouldn't give it back whatever it is
that they're looking for whether it's
documents or whatever the hell it is the
records that they're actually seeking
i think there's a possibility that he
not only gave them to a third party
which is even a higher crime not just
retaining and taking it that's a higher
crime that's all that's always been a
felony that's the one where they have
actually prosecuted people but i think
it's possible to imagine that donald
trump would sell these things yeah yeah
and we know we know the guy's broke so
he's desperate he'll do whatever he can
the saudis gave jared kushner 2 billion
was something exchanged
for that dollar amount i want to know
well um
this tweet is fantastic i don't know
have you heard of the gay guy candle
company i didn't come across them until
somebody sent me a tweet from there and
i don't know if it was this one or was a
different one this is hilarious
it says when you're the fbi they let you
do it
um and then they made a candle and it
says the fbi moved on him like a [ __ ]
oh come on this is fantastic
this is fantastic yeah i've seen it yet
you've done him like a [ __ ] i've seen a
lot of people say
like giving giving statement like fake
statement quotes you know from the fbi
and they're like it's been quoted by the
fbi that they moved on him like a [ __ ]
well i well i mean that's really kind of
what they did because he was in new york
i think that was part of the plan right
um and i actually think that uh before
he pays someone to push ivana i mean
ivana fell down the stairs
um i it's you know that's out there too
right right right i don't know that but
but when she fell down the stairs and
passed away from that accident
and he was not able to give the
deposition and he was going to be in new
york for the deposition i actually
believe that the fbi probably would have
made their move then when he was
originally going to do the deposition
you know what else could be well keep
going well because i think i figured
that's why that's why they did this
during this time is because he had to be
in new york like he was in new jersey
but he didn't have to be there he could
fly down to mar-a-lago in the same time
he wanted but he couldn't get away from
new york with this deposition right he
couldn't that's there's nothing he could
do he had to be there right physically
for that deposition so
i don't know
what if i'm just saying
what if and i wouldn't put it past him
so he has to have this deposition right
in new york and maybe he gets whispers
if things are moving you know maybe the
fbi's involved whatever like somebody
got you know he's coming for you
he goes nope cam can't be in new york
can't do that gotta go to mar-a-lago
goes to mar-a-lago make sure to say hey
guys
uh
we need to [ __ ] hide this [ __ ] right
right and he puts it in ivana's coffin
and it's crazy buried
at mar-a-lago
and bad misery i'm just saying like what
because
i don't want to be one of those
conspiracy theories but i am i wonder i
want i
but what if
the timing is weird i'm just saying but
what if
certain documents or things are in that
coffin well so that's a good point i
think i think you know because
supposedly they cremated her so there's
question of what is in the coffin
anyways
um that is buried there at the uh in a
ditch off the off the first hole at
betminster because it's it's buried
right near a ditch which is kind of
um you know can't make this [ __ ] up
because it's it's it's spot on but
i think you're off the mark i think the
actual theory is here and the thing that
they're looking for
is proof that he does not possess
documents that they know he sold because
i think what has happened
is he sold or gave away somehow these
documents got into possession of someone
other than himself and he probably sold
them
and the fbi and the national archives
found out about that
and i think the several times that the
national archives has went to mar-a-lago
to get those documents fbi was embedded
with those teams
as one of those teams and that's where
these fbi agents went to this judge and
said here's the evidence that we have we
cannot find
these whatever they are that is
supposedly sold to someone else or in
the possession of someone else and we
need to find out if he gave them away
and the only way to find out if they
gave them away
is or or the opposite of that
right so if he gave these or if he's
claiming he didn't give these away but
the fbi and national guys are claiming
that he gave them away the easiest thing
for him to do would just be to give
those things and it would be proof that
he didn't give him away if he had yeah
but i think that's the problem here
that's the problem and everyone keeps
you know making different suggestions
about this i think the
the fair bear facts are he took these
things he gave them or sold them to a
third party and he does not possess them
anymore and that's why they went down
there several times and couldn't find
these [ __ ]
they can't find these things because
they're not there he gave them away
and that is the problem that he has i
think that's his actual problem here
with this national archive thing is that
he has committed felonies not just by
taking them and retaining them
he has either given them away or sold
them through at their party and that's
where his that's where his his criminal
liability lies yeah speaking of
mar-a-lago
boy gabe have you seen this video of
this trump supporter
this is from reuters i was watching this
live uh i was like going to pick up food
and i stopped to check a notification
and obviously this is on the eighth when
everything was going down and this is
just like a live reuters camera that
caught this this is a live reuters
camera and so that's where like at the
moment i couldn't record it but i just
took a took a photo of it and was like
uh the people i was like yeah because
this was this was the night after yeah
this is everyone who's like out there on
the bridge walking with their signs and
like and i thought at first this was a
joke
i had to google this hat
and find out if this was a real or if
this was like a parody hat or like it
was because at first glance at first
glance you think oh this person's making
fun of a trumpet right like it it's it
this joke has been done before with
other kind of me like in scary movie
right the uh the the sheriff's hat or
scary movie three or four whatever was
the sheriff's hat gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and that's a joke right in
other movies like someone sipping a
glass of wine and the wine glass gets
bigger and bigger and bigger and in this
moment i for sure thought this was a
[ __ ] joke like a foam finger hat joke
like somebody's like oh i'm making fun
of you and i listened to the interview
as it was happening and i was like this
is not a joke this is [ __ ] real this
is real life and then i looked it up and
this is and people at these [ __ ]
rallies wear this [ __ ] that's not a joke
we are we are at the intersection of
wrestlemania and real life is the
problem here now the
i i tweeted what in the foam hat hell i
mean i can't even imagine a person
wearing this thing let alone
stand in front of a camera and try to
give a serious reason why yeah they are
saying this donald trump is the rightful
uh president i believe in this interview
let's listen
administration the democrats are
weaponizing the fbi and it has to stop
the fbi is not here to weaponize against
another president it never has happened
before
um actually the fbi has been used
against his name was nixon yeah um they
actually there was a criminal
investigation that was the whole point
that's why he actually did the honorable
thing and resigned and went away
like that's why
he realized what had happened he
realized why why he was going to be a
pariah and he did that thing and just
was became up there
the other thing here too is like
all of them are you going to say no i
wasn't even going to bring up the german
accent
i'll i okay you could bring it up i
wasn't i wasn't gonna go down that road
but you could you can go down the road
i'll follow you definitely go down that
girl what i was gonna say was
uh the talking points that she has at
the beginning of this interview all the
way to the end before she walks up with
another friend and they carry a sign
down the bridge because you watched that
you watched the whole yeah i watched
this they were just on the scene and
they were like oh would you like to talk
would you like to talk and don't wait
look at the lady with the big phone
let's get her to say something right but
what her talking points are are exactly
like
what i imagine they're listening to the
radio right-wing radio the listen to fox
news and everything that she says right
now the weaponization of the fbi against
a former president she doesn't really
expand on that more than an interview if
i remember correctly these are all
things that they got from fox news and
other right-wing media shows that were
like this is illegal unprecedented
uh this is unfair there you know there
was no warning this is the weaponization
of the fbi and law enforcement again in
the city or like against the former
president
that is all that they keep saying they
they just keep reading [ __ ]
if it was another government official if
it was another government official that
had done this they would act the same
way if that government official that
former government official would not be
complying and in fact they actually
jailed someone named reality
um
i'm telling you this is all president
this is the way that they react just
because you selected to follow behind
and do and to make your the head of your
party a criminal is the thing that is
unprecedented that is
it is unprecedented that he became a
president yeah and he is now a former
president it's not that when you commit
crimes the fbi and the justice
department comes after you but let's
listen to uh old foam hat here and let's
see what else brilliant things come out
from underneath her what appears to be a
really tiny head um they should go after
things that are clearly a violation
meaning the hunter
here it is which they don't even have to
investigate because they are eventually
right there all
the fbi has had hunter vines laptop for
like a year and a half right a year and
a half and they still they still also
brought charges but also what doesn't
help their their argument is the fact
that they keep showing around this
[ __ ] thumb drive and said i've got
the contents of hunter biden's laptop on
it the fact that you guys keep
exchanging hands and other you know
evidence of
evidence whether or not stuff gets put
on there or not
the fact that you have this thing and
you're trying to enter in a record here
and entering a record there like
if it really is a thing and you want to
complain about it and [ __ ] and moan and
say how this is totally unfair and i've
done all the contents of the illegal
things go to the fbi just like if you
have proof that the 2020 election was
was uh was rigged go to the fbi carrie
lake if you have proof that it was
antifa and it was blm at the january 6th
what are you waiting on right go to the
[ __ ] fbi you know there's a there's a
line
of of of how are you supposed to do this
you either go to local law enforcement
you can go to the federal law
enforcement you know you can't just like
make a claim and then go well they're
not investigating it well then why don't
you just give them the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they are investigating hunter biden
they're actually at a point right now
where they're determining what they're
gonna do and they have to decide if he
is you know if there's something there
or not but these people are like they're
not investigating it's like they
literally are investigated right and
they have well and back to the hunter
binds laptop and this bonehead here on
the screen because like you said before
they're just boneheads and they're
believing anything the little t that
little shiny tv thing will tell them
right on fox news and they believe it
and it's a hook line sinker and really
it's more cause to be concerned about
not just individual people but fox news
in general that keeps parroting this
stuff because that's what they said
moments after oh they went and kicked
down the door mar-a-lago when are they
gonna go arrest hunter biden like maybe
they will yeah you guys would just
[ __ ] shut up about it right and you
you're not helping your case
by complaining and and waving around a
thumb drive and doing this and doing
that like right you're only causing
hysteria and it people on the left had
been causing hysteria about the january
6 select committee and emerit garland
and they're not going to do anything
they're not going to charge trump
boy they yeah tom winslow don winslow
don't listen to him um
he's a dumbass um listen the thing is is
that they are doing these things they
are investigating they've been signaling
to you for a long time that they're
doing it by i don't know arresting
hundreds of people who were involved
in the [ __ ] january 6 insurrection
now now here is more evidence in a
separate case because this isn't even
this has nothing to do with january 6.
not a goddamn thing this has to do with
him committing another crime
right another crime and the best part
about it though and probably what
terrifies them the most is that they're
probably going to undercover uncover
evidence in the justice department of
the crime of january 6 in this search in
this
race that's what really [ __ ]
frightens him because really what he's
looking at here if they try to charge
him with the crime he can probably
wiggle his way out of this
if if now if he sold or gave away yeah
yeah to a third party he's really gonna
have a hard time wiggling out of it but
if he didn't actually do that which
we'll find out if he did or not right
but if he didn't actually give away to a
third party or sell to a third party of
these records he was just being a
bastard and wanted to keep these things
well remember they're also saying that
they
that trump's lawyer
went on the record on to fox news or
newsmax or somewhere and said that the
fbi planted well that means that you're
gonna find oh yeah they're gonna first
definitely evidence like that's the
projection right right we're always
looking for the projection that's the
projection when his attorney's like they
planted evidence you goddamn right
there's evidence you're gonna see
evidence american people but believe
it's planted please believe it's planned
and i can't wait for the moment that
when if
because i would hate for this to
actually happen but if
he did actually sell those secrets to
some other third-party country whoever
and it comes forward and they're like
yep we found out that this wasn't there
and then yet you know some there was
someone who said or they we found out
that he sold it to this person
i cannot wait to hear how fox news tries
to explain how selling the secrets to
some other place other than our own
government was doing us a favor because
they'll probably say well it was too big
of a thing for us to handle so we needed
trump thought with his very stable
genius mind that he should give it to
some other third party who was right
that way that way the
dark brandon can't get his exactly
just wait mark this day august 10th
wednesday
there will come a time when we find out
if we find out
that trump
did sell documents the
fox news and the right-wing media will
try to explain how he was doing america
a favor and protecting this country by
giving those
to a third party right well you know the
other
the other thing here too is with the the
evidence like that they planted evidence
because if you're gonna i mean you know
texas paul has said this several times
if you want to get inside the mind of
donald trump just just think like a
criminal right yeah so thinking thinking
let's say let's say you're a former
president gabe and you take this [ __ ]
you know it's illegal to take this [ __ ]
and you know it's definitely illegal to
sell this [ __ ] but you definitely want
to sell it because you're [ __ ] broke
you're [ __ ] broke and you have to
appear rich like not only are you broke
you have to appear rich so you really
got to sell the most valuable pieces of
this of the [ __ ] you sold
so would you would you like take a check
from someone like with the memo like uh
stolen stuff from the white house like
that's i mean
you would think that trump would just go
cash
or some other investment somewhere else
but well here's here's what my thought
is my thought is maybe gold bars maybe
jewelry maybe art i mean there could be
a lot of forms of payment that someone
could give
to donald trump that he could take
because then he could go
you know rip that somewhere else right
um for money yeah you know that's
like money was put into a swiss bank
account which you know
is the typical safe haven that people go
to when they're like hey i have money
and i need to oh surely he's remember
the country
come on you can come you can imagine
he's dumber than that imagine oh no no
totally that's why i said like you'd be
dumb enough to actually sign a check
imagine some russian mobster showing up
with like a painting uh like a whole a
whole duffel bag full of gold bars and
jewelry and and him and trump are in the
room and he's like this is fabulous this
is wonderful i'll be able to sell these
anywhere the most the greatest auction
why the greatest hockey it'll be the
most perfect auction yeah and then he
and then he proceeds to put all that
[ __ ] in his safe you know because he
wants to make sure that no one steals it
so he puts it in the safe i'm just
saying that this could be a movie this
is going to be a movie there you know
there there seems to be this whole like
saudi involvement it's like you've got
again jared jared kushner getting two
billion dollars you've got this golf
series that happens right with the
saudis and you know i'm not saying that
there's a link but who knows maybe
there's something there where like the
payments that he's received have been
through other parties or through other
means or events
i don't know well let's get back to this
video to see what this what the the the
the oh the great analysis of the foam
hat lady here hillary
all of that is not investigated
president trump is investigated because
they said that he's running
and he will win again
oh jesus so her analysis is now again
and that's not even the whole interview
right that's just the that's just one
piece of that yeah
she basically said the same thing
minutes before
you know
she kept repeating it yeah no correct no
no obstruction no collusion no
obstruction no collusion no abstraction
no collusion hillary's emails build a
wall hillary's emails hundreds mightin's
laptop hunter biden's laptop now a lot
of people um pointed out in the comments
about her accent some called it russian
some called it this some surmised that
maybe she was uh melania's cousin maybe
i don't know
now you pointed out that it's a
german accent
that's the accent after i listened to it
several times that i figured it was it
was german not really russian um which
to us americans these accents sometimes
sound very similar right yeah i mean i
mean i could say german or i could say
austrian you know right but those would
be the few places that i would say right
somewhere there in central europe right
yeah right but uh not not eastern
european or a russian
accent but again a lot of people pointed
out the accent and found it kind of uh
hilarious that it was uh someone with a
with a foreign accent you know maybe
russian and they were like oh did this
is this person the paid russian right
right which can you imagine again just
for movie and hollywood's sake oh can
you imagine can you imagine him slipping
a piece of jewelry to
melania's russian cousin
and given giving her a piece of jewelry
and like here here's it's like do you
have a make america greeting and hat i
can put on and he picks up the foam hat
and he's like go out there go out there
pulled it out of the [ __ ] costume bin
like uh and i got this one
you know this is the this is the best
hat it's the perfect hat everyone will
believe if i would actually pay money to
buy a hat it would have been it would
definitely like to buy a maga hat
outside of me just making a red hat with
with uh with paper on it i would go for
a foam hat for sure did you figure out
these you find them did you find them on
the internet yeah yeah i found them how
much how much are they here let me find
it again uh
how much are they the foam the foam
ridiculous manga hats so you can buy a
giant foam make america great again hat
where you can't even see the person's
face for 20 dollars and 24 cents well
goddamn that's probably true
than the ones that trump has made you
want to know where do you want to know
what store you buy it from what store do
you buy from it's called the
conservative comedy store
oh [ __ ] so so wait so is it a goof on it
or is it their choice i don't know
because
people at his rallies wear it so
you know i'm i'm also trying to find
like on you can find them on ebay you
can find them other places you can find
them on etsy
you know but the idea that they wear
these hats and they're real fans and
they go to these rallies is
is real that is that is a fact they i
mean this is wrestlemania or sports type
stuff right cause that's i mean you can
even buy a giant [ __ ] cowboy hat that
says make america great again again also
sold by the conservative comedy store so
how much is that one how much is that
one that one would be
28.99 oh my god so the weight that the
cowboy hand is more expensive than the
except here's the thing it's
they're
well
i don't know because it's
they're the the company is
is called a conservative comedy store
but in there it's called political
targets so you know like the peen you
know remember like the character p yeah
yeah yeah yeah
it's like that but
calvin and hobbes calvin knops right
exactly
so like this on chevy you put it on yeah
yeah yeah so they sell you toilet paper
and all this other stuff this no this is
definitely not a joke anymore because
these things are against democrats which
means that all the things that are sold
that have conservative messages on them
are real
uh giant cowboy hat giant what is keep
oh keep america great hat these are all
real genuine things because the things
that are attacking
people who are on
just attacking any political person but
but here's the he's on the left it could
be it could be one big [ __ ] joke you
know maybe maybe this is what we should
do gabe we should open up a store
and market it as
to own the libs right like own the libs
store.com some [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
we should open up a store
and give every single nickel
every single nickel of that money
to like planned parenthood or something
oh yeah something that they [ __ ] hate
well i've had that's what i did with uh
with christian walker i made those
shirts that were making fun of christian
walker and then i donated them to
different organizations that he hated
and i did that as a way to get after him
so and he didn't he did not find that
funny at all and i found it hilarious is
that why he blocked you is that why he
blocked you uh that's one of the reasons
why he blocked me right but you know i
was wearing the shirt i was promoting
the shirt in the videos people were
buying the shirt like and again all
proceeds i covered the cost all proceeds
went to these different organizations um
in his name by the way
so
they all had even better even better
even better well maybe we should
consider that you know the art
department is still working hard over
there
in the background on doubt me shirts
yeah so they're coming they're coming
the art department um
is in the bunker right now i'm sure
working hard we're finishing up the
bunker so we'll have things up and
running soon enough right right well uh
let's see i had some other video but i i
want to go to this um
this one here this is kind of crazy you
know who laura loomer is it's speaking
of this yeah
florida yeah yeah dude here i'll give
you a video of her and uh yeah let's do
that and walter yeah so here is here is
uh patriot takes
and i believe this is telegram is where
she's posting it is that right yeah
that's okay okay so uh
pedro takes his florida republican
candidate now she's a candidate for
congress folks remember this she's a
candidate for congress she's on the
ballot
and she you have the ability if you're
in her district to go vote against her
remember that um the canaan laura loomer
says if the fbi arrests trump
quote
the revolution in america will begin so
this is this civil war talk right which
has been going on she says in this
telegram the fbi laura loomer the
candidate for congress the nazi
candidate for congress
it's really weird because i've got
another one i want to show you too here
if i can find it quickly another uh one
she she talked about she says the fbi is
going to try to arrest president trump
in an ambush which she's making stuff up
here which i actually would encourage
this yeah this is great i love her
imagination here gabe i love her
imagination
and she goes on to say and when they do
that the revolution in america will
begin and i believe that's the truth too
your imagination is great i believe the
revolution back towards democracy will
begin
at his ambush arrest by the fbi she goes
on to say
if you take our president which is kind
of gross you take all of us i don't know
what that means exactly because we're
going down we're not going down without
a fight and so she's threatening
violence here it seems i stand with
president trump hashtag lord loomer for
congress
do you have hashtags on on i guess i
have hashtags on i mean you could write
a hashtag i don't know if they're
actually close yeah i don't want to go
on telegram right neither maybe we
should go over there and really just
kind of [ __ ] with these people so that's
that's what laura loomer says there on
telegram there's another telegram if you
can find that why i play this video that
you pulled up remember the one that
she's self-hating herself
um oh
you follow me yeah let's see um here is
uh here's the video
where her and walter have an exchange
um about cancel culture because she she
not only is a candidate for congress of
course she wrote a book
and of course she
claims just like the rest of them
that her book is being canceled let's
watch walter ask her about her book
being canceled another thing we're
talking about cancel culture what do you
think about cancer culture well you know
i am the most banned woman in the world
and so i have a lot to say about council
culture she's the most banned woman in
the world gabe
in the world let's watch just wrote a
book about it she wrote a book about him
in the book it's called bloomer how i
became the most banned woman in the
world oh yeah make sense can they find
the book well it's on barnes noble you
can go to barnes and noble and you can
go to my website well we all know we all
know barnes noble is a right-wing
bookstore i mean we all know that i
didn't okay here's the thing when i when
walter sent me this video uh like last
week i think yeah yeah he dropped it he
dropped it to me too and i yeah yeah and
uh i didn't i know barnes noble was
still a thing
no i was like i was like borders closed
i just assumed no no no no no no no no
no barnes no no there are some
some actual brick and mortar stores but
it's online it's online i i totally
assume
that amazon had taken over and all these
bigger places barnes and noble still
still exist online mainly but i think
they have they do have brick and mortar
stores but let's listen let's listen to
all the places that it's not because
she's been cancelled gabe so remember
you should be banned right cancelled
only be able to find it probably one or
two places but let's listen to one
definitely in her bag there that's one
place that happens right
copies as well not on amazon
well
amazon did they are carrying it you know
i am the most banned woman in the world
and so i have a lot to say about council
culture there is canceled culture uh but
you know you gotta you gotta keep you
gotta keep uh pushing through regardless
you can't let them stop you
so she's calling that people won't buy
her book cancel culture it's really
stupid like that's exactly what walter's
getting at here right he's like they're
not buying my book so it's cancelled
culture like no your book sucks
there's consequences and the
consequences of writing a stupid [ __ ]
book is that no one's gonna read it no
one's gonna buy it that's the
consequence that you have
loomered
she got loomered i would listen to
everybody who lives in her district in
florida and if you know anybody who
lives in her dick let's loom her ass
right out of the race anyone who lives
in the uh the florida district 11 please
go vote against her on august 23rd right
august 20th
13 days less than two weeks away show
her what loomerd means really means what
consequence culture really is because
that other the other um telegram that
she had and i don't know patriot takes
had it or so the one i sent you i don't
it's not it's on the telegram this one
is about covet is that the one you're
talking about no no no it's about it's
about
her being jewish
oh
oh
yeah that one
it's even crazy this is some crazy [ __ ]
you think the one
where she's talking about um
um
uh
the the the the
civil war thing is crazy
here's where she is justifying
here's where she's justifying
um hitler
i mean it it's it's really kind of gross
it's like it's it's kind of like jews
for nazis is what it seems like yeah be
quite honest with you
is this doing trouble from august 4th
no no no
this no it was her writing the statement
oh okay it was her writing the statement
um
it's not this one's from stu peters yeah
yeah
now she does she does talk about because
she's talking about white christian
nationalism
she might have to search uh loomer white
christian oh got it got it got it it's
from the eighth this is from the eighth
yeah so this was just a couple days ago
uh when i saw this i was like ooh this
is
this is really gross like this is super
great juice for hitler
it is
oh that's what this is that's what she's
doing it's it's really disgusting so
here is uh let me i mean
there we go
pull this up pager takes posted this as
well
apparently patriot takes is definitely
all over her telegram uh florida
republican laura loomer the quote is i'm
jewish
but i know and i recognize that
christian nationalism
nationalist platform is the best
political platform for america's future
oh it gets grosser
it gets grosser than that here's the
full telegram i guess that's what it's
called
i'm jewish she says
but i know and recognize that christian
nationalist platform is the best
political platform for america's future
and the america first movement which we
all know is fascists and nazis nazis
they're nazis she's goes on this and she
is she is pointing out in this in this
statement i think she knows their nazis
she's like i know they're nazis but even
though i'm jewish right yeah she goes on
to say here's the bottom here's the
justification the butt part i'm a jewish
american nationalist
in support of christian nationalist
movement
and i'm not afraid to say it
it is mind-boggling she's basically
saying i'm a jew for american nazis i
support america nazis even though i'm
jewish like she's literally pointing out
that the america first christian
national white christian national
movement is nazis right because i mean
the self-hating aspect of this message
right here it hurts me
for the reason that i can relate to
other people within like the hispanic
community who don't you know who who
want to speak against them in a racist
or you know derogatory way like it's the
same thing here you've got someone who
is jewish who is acknowledging the
america first amendment who we we have
seen
and acknowledging and acknowledging
that's yeah pro-nazi and against jews
right
and then saying i am
a jewish american nationalist in support
of christian nationalist movement like
it's like it's it says it's edited so
i'm curious what the original version
was
right you know if she took it
away i'm not afraid to say it i don't
know can we is there a way
because the way back machine doesn't
work for one certain websites it might
not work for telegram in that way um
that you can actually pull up the
unedited um but that's the thing gabe is
she actually edited this
and this is the edited version yeah so
like it was worse than this
it was way worse than this
i i just this is and and this is the
republican party at this point right
this is the this is the the oh democrats
want to defund the police and as soon as
marjorie taylor greene scott perry which
i want to talk about before we leave
here scott perry matt gatz um all these
republican politicians jim jordan who
were involved in crimes go oh defund the
federal police so they can't raid us
next like that's literally what they're
saying they want to defund the police so
they can't come after them
it really is it's it's [ __ ] something
else to watch it really yeah because
she's
she says in her telegram right now she
goes thank you nick fuentes for the
amazing endorsement and kind comments
about my campaign and your fabulous show
america first tonight oh well
great work
if anyone knows who nick fuentes is he's
a holocaust denier yep and the reason
why he's supporting laura loomer
is this statement right here is because
she's saying even though i'm a jew i
support nazis
even though i'm a jew i support the
american
the american nazi party which is the
republican party
is what she's saying that's why nick
valente is a supporting her did you hear
that scott perry got his cell phone
seized holy i did i did oh man
you know
and everyone thinks that this has
something to do with the mar-a-lago
thing which i think it has nothing to do
with it no this is for sure going to be
about the fact that you know
uh this has been involved in january 6.
yeah yeah this state the state electors
because i believe that there were
certain members of congress who were
physically in possession
of these fake state electors and i
believe that the mastermind behind the
state elector's scam and that that scam
to try to steal our government away
which is john eastman
okay that's the architect right he's the
architect of the the scheme of the fake
electors here to get to get mike pence
to to get the state electors we know
through the january six depositions that
he was pressuring the white house
attorneys and he was also pressuring
mike pence's attorneys to do this thing
and mike pence was looking for any way
to legally do it but every at every turn
mike pence was told no it is a crime and
mike pence is not a hero he just didn't
want to go to prison
but scott perry was in communication
with john eastman he was one of the
congressmen in communication with john
eastman about these fake state electors
i actually believe
gabe can you imagine that
when they took john eastman's phone that
they were able to get the communications
between him and scott perry oh yeah i
would imagine that's why they won they
were so interested in scott perry's
phone because i would bet
i would bet money that the
communications that they were receiving
on john eastman's phone which is one way
from scott perry right it's just a
one-way street at that point
i bet scott perry in those
communications talks about other people
he's talking to and i bet that's the
reason why the department of justice
wants to see scott perry's phone because
they want to see the two-way street of
the communications that scott perry was
having to overthrow our government and
take away our democracy i bet that's the
reason why what do you think i think oh
100 and also like we have to keep in
mind that cassidy hutchinson has
testified right and given her statement
about how after a meeting with meadows
right meadows was burning documents
so you know they're like oh i don't know
anything about that and you know scott
perry doesn't want to
uh you know follow subpoena to give
testimony to or give a death position
right there's a lot of sketchy stuff
he's like
why for all of the things that she has
come forward she's put her life at risk
right she's had death threats and other
things against herself why would she
come forward and lie about
something that like if she's already
coming forward like
it doesn't do her any good to lie right
it doesn't do her any good to make up
more of the story and so when she goes
oh yeah meadows is burning documents
after meeting with perry that's very sus
like that is something you would be like
and you think you think she would
actually remember that like she's not
just making right that's like something
i don't you know and what context it was
a bin or an incinerator or whatever but
he was i think he was burning them in
his office so i'm assuming like in a
little trash can
but
that i know of i don't know it could
have been somewhere else but the fact
that they were burning documents we know
trump was uh they were shredding
documents trump was eating documents
they were flushing documents like
i 100 believe this story to be true
based on the other things that have been
documented by maggie haberman and the
other people who have come forward on
her book
and when you look at this and say oh
yeah they got the phone i go yeah not
surprised i guarantee he's you know
either in a great chat with someone yeah
on the phone
i think is just what
what i laid out is that they were seeing
one-way communications from scott perry
with john eastman about us the scheme to
get these electors in the hand of mike
pence
and he was talking to john eastman and
telling him about other communications
that he had with other people about this
scheme and that's why they wanted the
two-way street communication from scott
perry's phone to see who he was who he
was talking to because he had to have
told john eastman that he was talking to
someone i believe that's why they went
after his phone and and they've done it
so quickly after
they have they have done forensics on
john eastman's phone and his
communications and i believe that it's
not going to stop at scott perry that's
why marjorie taylor green that's why jim
jordan that's why matt gatz that's why a
lot of these people are freaking out i
think ron johnson has a reason to be
freaking out because apparently the
wisconsin
fake electors were being were being
lifted through his office and he didn't
want to touch him he's even said in
public he's like i didn't touch them it
was my staff and he's trying to push
this off on his staff that they were
trying to deliver him because i think
that's the thing here is you're going to
see a criminal indictments against
members of congress and their staff for
physically possessing these fake
electors knowing their fake collectors
and knowing this scheme because they all
sent out that [ __ ] presentation they
sent out the email they were trying to
steal our democracy they were trying to
take our vote away from us folks and and
and that it is gonna go on and i can't
wait i can't wait gabe next month season
two season two of the january six select
hearings come and i almost bet liz
cheney put scott perry back in her mouth
because that significance here is they
knew this evidence existed because liz
cheney said it directly into a
microphone and called scott perry out
and now the department of justice is all
up in his [ __ ] all the way up in his
[ __ ] so stay tuned folks don't forget to
subscribe here at the johnny michaels
podcast because those hearings are gonna
come up in september but stay tuned
until then
any news that comes across the wire we
will be covering here on the tony
michael's podcast also do not forget to
follow us at tony michael's pod we will
be doing the bone end of the week
poll bonet of the week
where we where we
have a poll for bone end of the week you
vote you decide we break it down every
friday so go follow us over there and
don't forget to download every single
episode on apple spotify google your
favorite directory and leave us a great
review while you're there downloading
every single episode seven days a week
and don't forget to come watch us live
here on youtube monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday every
single weekday for two full hours on
youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the midas touch
facebook page until tomorrow at noon
eastern gabe
you know what
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking